comment s'occuper de sa chevelure quand
on est enfermé chez soi
votre confinement des professionnels
donnent leurs conseils sur les réseaux
sociaux mais comores faisait ton avant
l'ère d'internet qu'on peut soins
couleurs la beauté du cheveu à domicile
c'est l affaire du petit écran
vos cheveux sont comme vous ils ont
besoin d'air et d'oxygène
le casse-tête premier en ces jours de
confinement c'est les cheveux trop longs
de nos enfants vous n'avez pas la
technique
en voici une proposée en 1959 dans
l'émission le magazine féminin première
étape les mèches sans couper une à une
assez régulièrement deuxième étape les
cheveux sont mouillés cela vous inquiète
mademoiselle cela permet d'égaliser la
coupe séchoir et brosses et c'est la
troisième étape
vous voyez que la leçon a profité même
si l'enfant est un peu et qui sont
toujours dans ce fameux magazine féminin
en 1960
cette fois ce sont des conseils pour
l'entretien des cheveux d'adultes un
massage de stimulation pour le cuir
chevelu de la nuque au top vos demain
commence par des rotations concentriques
diriger vers le franc et vous insistez
aux endroits qui se dénude si vite sur
le front masculin
puis vous placez vos doigts à la lisière
du franc et de la chevelure et vous
procédez à des vibrations percutante
latéral en avançant vers le milieu de la
tête
vous devez sentir que le cuir chevelu se
détache de l'os crânien vous recommencez
deux ou trois fois ce salutaire scalp
abrégé si vous êtes en panne de produits
cosmétiques tournez vous plutôt vers
l'émission dim dam dom quelques
ingrédients et un peu d'huile de coude
pour des cheveux est splendide sens
c'était en 1965 et citron au rinçage du
souffle du camphre et lui lui luis oliva
manque tournesol pour les fatiguer les
sectes les faibles et misérable et
nerveuse et énervé alors suralimentation
à l'huile
oui on nourrit les mèches et me paraît
en passant l'huile de la pointe à la
racine
tu dis de la pointe à la racine et de
façon à 10 est lui sous les écailles du
cheveu en apprennent en entortille tu en
tires bien bien absorber ça réussit mais
vraiment je dis s'il est si vraiment
tout ça ne vous inspire rien vous pouvez
toujours compter sur kazim ou roue de
coups et voilà le cheddar terminée
[Musique]